but first redefining and disarming
america
that's the focus of tonight's angle
now the hardcore left that now basically
owns the democrat party
has been hard at work for decades the
redefining terms
concepts and historical events all for
one purpose
to redefine what america itself means
and also to take away our freedoms thus
basic terms of for instance biology
are redefined the factual
classifications of male
and female are continually expanded
beyond sex to include
dozens of gender categories all without
regard
to science my pronouns are she her and
hers
i am committed to doing the absolute
most to protect black mothers
to protect black birthing people
the term illegal alien or even illegal
immigrant
is branded xenophobic even when it's
factual
no human being is illegal we are
all children of god what you cannot do
is to label a person
illegal there is no such thing as an
illegal human
don't you miss her candidacy now the
term racism is redefined and thrown
around
casually supplemented with adjectives
like systemic and structural
most white people are oblivious to
systemic racism and inequality
simply because they don't experience it
every single day of their lives
now sometimes the manipulation of
language is designed to
excuse and eventually to normalize
aberrant behavior
remember back in 1999 when a popular
president
obliterated the boundaries of english
and even
managed to redefine the present tense of
the verb
to be stated that there was no sex
of any kind in any manner shape or form
of president clinton
was an utterly false statement is that
correct
it depends upon what the meaning of the
word is
yes how he ever recovered from that one
statement is beyond me still after all
these years
now fast forward to the present day
language manipulation directly
impacting our second amendment rights
now biden's nominee to head the atf
unwittingly revealed how democrats have
used language
to deprive us of basic freedoms when
senators today
pinned him down do you believe in
banning assault weapons
i do sir okay define assault weapons
um assault weapons would be something
that
members of congress would define well
how do you define it
you're going to be running the agency
senator
um the bill to ban assault weapons
what is your thousands of pages there's
no way i could define an assault weapon
give me your definition
i can give you one definition if you
want to answer my question how can i
vote for you
i'm done mr chairman i don't think i'm
gonna get an answer
oh when senator tom cotton got his shot
he hit a bull's-eye can you tell me
what is an assault weapon how would you
define it
if you were the chair the head of the
atf how have you defined it over the
last several years
as your role as a gun control advocate i
know there's a demand letter
three program which requires multiple
reports atf in that program has defined
an assault rifle
as any semi-automatic rifle capable of
accepting a detachable
magazine um above the caliber of 22
which would include a 2-2-3 which is
you know largely the ar-15 round i'm
amazed
that that might be the definition of
assault weapon that would basically
cover
every single modern sporting rifle in
america today
oh that's all but look language matters
and the term assault weapon itself is
made up and meaningless
it's just meant to scare people into
thinking they should be banned and no
matter what democrats say
it will be used to justify an eventual
confiscation of guns in america
senator feinstein's bill which a super
majority
of senators voted against in a
democratic senate you said that bill
didn't go far enough and you wanted an
even broader ban
senator feinstein's bill did not
address those firearms that are
currently in the possession of americans
those firearms could be treated under
the nfa and regulated that way
you don't just want to make it illegal
to sell those rifles
but you want to actively have government
go after the people who currently
possess
firearms and if they don't register and
submit
to all of the onerous restrictions of
the national firearms act presumably
confiscate their weapons
i prefer a system where the ar-15
and other assault weapons are regulated
under the national farms act
oh does that comfort you look biden has
pretended to be a moderate on gun rights
but he surrounded himself with radicals
like that guy
who publicly ridicule gun owners
they might think that they're die hard
ready to go
but unfortunately they're more like
tiger king and
they're putting themselves and their
families in danger
hide it behind the cans of tuna and beef
jerky that you've stored in a cabinet
and you know only bring that out if the
zombies start to appear
the zombie apocalypse that's the only
reason people own guns
now it's obvious that this guy who's
representing joe biden's views
does not believe in the second amendment
and does not believe that americans
should be trusted with guns period
we know what this means what it's going
to look like right only criminals will
have guns and innocent people will be at
risk
now all over the country left-wing
cities are being destroyed right now by
crime
new york chicago baltimore minneapolis
california has among the toughest gun
laws in the nation
the assault weapons ban that chipman
wants and yet a deranged man
still shot and killed eight people there
today in san jose
so the left's position on guns is not
only unconstitutional
it's utter madness especially when
combined with their
hatred of the police so
wherever the left ends up gaining power
criminals
end up being emboldened and good people
find themselves in more danger
it's tragic that so many people in our
cities have fallen prey to the left's
lies
and they blame their problems on the
honest gun owners of this country
we have to keep doing everything we can
to alert the good people
of crime ridden cities who live there
that there is a better way
but in the meantime the gop and every
sane democrat must steadfastly resist
any effort to promote the left's
pro-crime agenda
the positions they're taking are
contrary to our constitution
they're immoral and they're insane no
matter what democrats say
no matter how they try to manipulate
language and hide the truth
we all have to recognize the reality
they want to take all privately owned
guns in the country
and prevent americans from owning guns
ever again
that's their true position as it has
been since the 1960s
and we have to resist it with everything
we've got
because once our freedoms are lost
they're very difficult to regain and
that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else